c'est la dernière étape d'un long
périple
plus qu'un simple trajet vienne munich
un train express pour une nouvelle vie à
bord des centaines de migrants en
majorité syrien fatigué épuisé la
plupart n'ont pas fermé l'oeil depuis
deux jours et dans le wagon 21 la
famille jarama et trop fébrile pour
dormir
incapable de choisir son pays d'adoption
on n'a pas encore décidé si on veut
aller en allemagne ou en hollande il va
c'est dans une carte ils discutent des
mérites respectifs des deux pays sans
jamais avoir mis les pieds
ahmad le père penche pour l'allemagne
allait lancer ou germany bybowl good
un glaive goudal avio une perspective
qui enchante sa fille bayane elle qui
rêve d'y faire des études de médecine
ils disent que l'allemagne c'est bien
pour l'éducation dit elle les rares
maçon sur la route depuis un mois ils
ont traversé huit pays en autobus en
bateau à pied on a traversé des
montagnes la mer des jambes
j'en ai plus d by al malik non lic alors
que le train approche de munich
tous prennent davantage attention
paysage avant le grand saut dans
l'inconnu
j'espère que les européens vont voir que
nous sommes des gens bien dit elle que
nous ne sommes pas méchants
à l'arrivée un moment de confusion voire
d'inquiétude les rares ma ne savent pas
où aller
mais les applaudissements qui
retentissent dans la gare à leur passage
viennent vite et rassurer contrairement
à beaucoup de pays traversés
les migrants sont ici les bienvenus je
suis heureuse de voir des gens aussi
gentils dit wap à des milliers de
migrants sont déjà arrivés ici en
quelques jours alors le processus est
bien rôdé après une visite médicale
les rares humains sont dirigés vers des
autocars direction le centre d'accueil
et d'hébergement
tous ils nous ont laissés choix d'y
aller ou non précise wafa ajoutant que
la famille en profitera pour réfléchir
ou s'installer et d'abord dit elle je
prendre une douche
au moment de choisir un pays d'adoption
l'accueil et la générosité des allemands
risquent fort de presser dans la balance
ici jean françois bélanger au canada
munich